hey it's Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today I'm doing another one of my Fiverr
gigs where I'm reviewing a website
someone who needs help and this time
it's not just somebody I know it's one
of my master my members named steven
rosen and his website his star results I
haven't checked out a site in a while so
he asked for some feedback this is a
good surprise and I will see we can give
him now Steven helps sales managers
perform better so basically he takes
sales people who are graded sales but
suck at managing the team and he helps
them become sales leaders so here we got
in developing sales leaders so looking
at the site I like the professional
designer like the logo like this section
here you know looks like you've you've
done some work to find a professional
design it maybe is a little bit
cluttered but overall ok to start with
I'm noticing a few things here that are
being pulled from my side some so maybe
best practices this part here let me let
me show you guys my site so here right
like it please +1 it thanks we basically
got word for word like it please + want
to thank so you're ripping off my code
Steven but no that's okay I'm glad to be
able to share some best practices you're
just missing the signature I've got the
oven here the other thing is there's a
tool here that I use on a site called
add this that allows people to share it
print it tweet it whatever and that
looks like Stevens done that as well so
hey wait a way to copy some best
practices and see if it works for you or
not now for SEO I know steven is trying
to drive people to his site who are
sales managers one of the keywords is
trying to rank for sales management
training or sales management coaching or
consulting one of the things we're going
to look at right away for Google is your
your title tag and here this is your
title tag it reads leadership and
management coaching transforms managers
to leaders so nothing about sales so you
definitely want to put sales management
coaching sales management training
whatever the most important keyword is
right up there that's the easy quick fix
the next thing I do is you want to have
content and especially your home page it
gives you your best chance of ranking
you have a page rank 3 here on your
homepage I put at least 500 words of
content and talk about
what makes you special what's your
mantra you know even what we what I just
talked about at the the opening of this
video how sales people suck at managing
people they're great at sales but they
they're not great sales managers is that
a whole new skill to learn and you can
help them put in something like that in
would help you not only convert people a
little bit better but also drive more
targeted traffic it'll help you boost
your rankings for that keyword let's dig
it a little more so here's a picture of
Stephen and that's a that's one of his
videos let's dig in on the about Stephen
page and see what we can find it's great
to have an about page again it looks
really professional it's nice smiling
picture maybe a little bit dated but
it's great to have a nice smiling
picture again it looks a little thin on
the content so I add more content in
here again at least 500 words I'd may be
subdivided with with bolded sub
headlines to make it easier to read and
if you're up for it since you're already
doing video make this video to make the
about stephen video that makes me want
to watch and help build a personal
relationship with the people who are
coming to your site if somebody is going
to sit there and watch your video then
you have a much greater chance of
converting them to have them contact you
or buy your book or whatever you want
them to do next I saw up here something
about testimonials I was here in the in
the NAB does asset testimonials link but
there doesn't seem to be anything here
on the about page so I definitely link
it not just have it in your nav because
people may miss that and testimonials
are key like you have it buried here on
your navigation where I'd put it front
and center probably take one or two of
your best ones and put them up on your
homepage as well because it shows that
people are saying good things about you
and not just you saying about yourself
so we've got some great feedback here
it's great you're putting their logos in
the name of the person so it's more
credible the design is nice what's
missing what I try to do is have
pictures of people if you can find it
here's one Susan MacLennan and very
short or she helped me break through key
issues that were holding my business
back from growth I don't think I could
have done as effectively or quickly
without his help it's a great
testimonial we've got a logo here but I
love to see up
picture if you can for each person so
Susan MacLennan let's do a quick Google
search see what we can find on her
Babylon is that the company Babylon yeah
so let's click on Babylon to an image
search to see we can find so Susan
MacLennan no real picture on here let's
see with the Google search ha so we've
got some pictures here I don't know if
that Susan MacLennan or not but
basically what you want to do it looks
like it is a media media public
relations and media training like that's
a great picture that'll add a lot more
to your testimonials page then then just
having the name wow I don't know how
this guy shows up for Susan MacLennan
anyway that's an interesting picture
back to the topic okay so this is a
great page again I'd make this more
front and center have a link on the
about page and have one or two key
testimonials on your homepage as well to
help show more social proof and
credibility let's move on what else can
we find here so let's get into our
services so services looks like you have
one main kind of category page for
everything and then you drill down into
more pages coaching speaking consulting
and training again very thin on content
there's no way this page is going to
rank for anything so you want to spruce
these up maybe done more work on the
actual pages themselves so sales
management training oh this is a big one
for Steven this is what he wants to get
more basically more clients who are
interested in his sales management
training services so this will be a key
page his greatest got a hearing in a
title tag he's got it in a URL sales
range of training he's got it here in
his content that's great but again the
content looks pretty thin not enough
words so 500 words plus on each page and
I'd probably wouldn't I don't know why
you did this well you have people have
to click on the plus each time I just
give them the information you're making
them do more work and I don't think it's
going to help you so more content and
make it simpler because this would be a
great page you try to get ranked so you
don't have to spend money on Adwords and
I've
Tyson to get people to come in you can
rank organically for these kinds of
keywords maybe a couple more links let's
look at the blog so we got I know steve
is a is a writer on on my side too and
it's pretty active so he's he thinks of
content marketing as a key strategy for
him which is great and I agree so this
is the most recent blog post it's nice
that the design is consistent across all
the pages so it's great again
professionally looking so this is his
article not but I mean not judging the
content quality but just looking at the
designer looks ok again it doesn't look
like it's enough words if you're going
to spend time writing articles i
definitely recommend spending time
writing 500-plus words and writing fewer
of them because you're going to get a
bigger bang for your buck you're going
to get more traffic Google likes longer
articles then these short ones that will
not help drive a ton of traffic so
something to think about and then maybe
let's just check out this contact page
if I want to do business with Stephen
what do I have to do so we've got we've
got all the information squares a
contact form you'll find people don't
often fill that out too much but it's
great to have other options so we've got
the address phone number office in
mobile we've got an email website
business hours it's great social media
network that's awesome i notice at the
top to the social media is here and also
the phone number and email address are
at the top of every page which is great
I maybe make that a clickable link so
people don't have to copy paste but
that's definitely a great thing to have
make it easy to be able to get in touch
with you so one one quick look again at
the homepage wait for that to load up so
steven rosen off the coach speaker i'm
going to give him a little plus one so
you're a 23 now Steven I hope you
enjoyed this video hope you got some
good feedback from it for those are you
watching if you liked it please give it
a thumbs up below it makes fun to do
more for you and if you have a question
about Steven's website or
by your own business I'd love to try to
answer for you if you want to leave it
in the comments section below thanks
guys so much and I'll see you soon